One of the one of the questions
that I've had throughout
this classified documents case is why?
Why did he do this?
And I've asked a lot of people who know
Donald Trump well why they think it is.
You obviously know Donald Trump well.
Here is a couple
here are a couple of theories
I asked of former Secretary of defense
under Trump. Mark Esper.
I want to get your reaction to this.
I I've heard two different theories
as to why he had these documents.
One from Stephanie Grisham, who said
he just like,
you know,
these are mine
and he's like a child with a toy
And one from Michael Cohen.
He said he thought that
Trump had these documents
because he wanted to use them
to further his own power or financial
well-being in some way.
Why do you think he held on
to these documents
and went to such lengths
to stop them,
to prevent them from being
turned over to the government
Yeah, look, I think both
theories can be true
and like they are true to some extent.
I have to admit,
I was kind of surprised
that Esper said that
because the idea
that he would use these secrets
to further his own power,
financial well-being,
is a shocking thing for him to think.
What do you think?
I think it was purely ego.
I think, Jake, he could not
and still cannot to this day
deal with the fact
that he's
the only person outside
the state of Delaware
to ever lose to Joe Biden.
And he wants to pretend
he's still president.
He takes these boxes with him
like he flies
them up there in New Jersey.
Now, if he still had them,
they'd be in New Jersey
because they go on
summer vacation with him.
I mean,
he wanted to continue
to pretend he was president
and show these things to people
and say, look,
I still have work with I still know.
So it's all part of the kabuki
about people telling him,
oh, you're still president.
You actually won that whole.
Yes, absolutely. I think that's it.
And I will tell you that
I've seen him with it's
not the first time
also with boxes of documents in 2016
when I was campaigning with him,
his bodyguard at the time,
he sure would have a box of bankers,
box of documents
that would go everywhere with him
when he was campaigning.
And whenever he got on the plane,
he would put that box of chocolates
right next to Donald Trump on the plane.
He would open them.
Now those documents for Trump
were from Trump Tower
and were business
related and also newspaper
articles, whatever.
And he,
he wanted that box
next to him immediately.
Before we took off.
So the talk about
the Beautiful Mind documents
that the staff is talking about,
he was obsessed about it.
There's an element to that as well.
And I thought
going all the way back to 20, 16.
I want to ask you about
what's happening in Ukraine right now,
because you're running
to be commander in chief, obviously.
And your fellow
Republican contender
Mike Pence said on the Hugh
Hewitt Show yesterday
that if Ukraine is defeated in the war,
the U.S.
will ultimately,
he fears,
have to send troops to fight
Russia's further aggression.
He seemed to be suggesting that
Russia would go and the U.S.
would need to defend
fellow NATO's allies,
which is required by charter.
Do you agree?
Look, I
don't think
I don't think that's necessarily true.
But what I do
think is
that this has huge
geopolitical implications, Jake.
We have to make sure
that we send a very clear message
not only to Russia,
but quite frankly,
they're my third concern
in this trifecta.
China and Iran,
China and Iran
are both actively
supporting Russia in this effort
with both military hardware and cash
to support Russia's effort in use.
Iranian drones, for example,
Iranian drones are killing civilians
every week in Ukraine.
And if we do not stand with Ukraine
and help them to win this war,
the message that it sends to Iran
is they can do whatever they want to do
in the Middle East,
including vis-a-vis Israel.
It will change the way
Saudi Arabia has to conduct itself
in the Middle East
because of freeing Iran up
to do these things.
And China will be looking
voraciously at Taiwan
This is already a proxy war
with China and Iran.
We have to win that proxy war.
Quite frankly,
Russia's my third concern in all this.
Very interesting.